we are doing a very special round of
drew's crew and a so let's get into it
first up is a question right here in our
studio audience it's yvette attila's and
i would love to know your question
hi jerome hi michael so i'm in the i'm
in the process of purchasing my new home
congratulations and as you know it's
very expensive
so my question is what furniture should
i be thinking about investing
and what furniture should i sort of
think about
buying in the cheaper end of it so
here's the thing with that typically you
want to spend the big bucks on the
things or the surfaces that you're going
to touch the most i.e like your bed your
sofa your coffee table things that
you're going to have a lot of high
traffic now you can kick back a little
bit on smaller things like bookcases
floating shelves things that people
aren't going to touch as much it's a
matter of finding things that are not so
expensive but functional and if it's
like crappy keep it somewhere up hidden
so nobody even sees that thing
okay thank you yvette for your question
all right next is a social media
question from rosalia flores on facebook
and she asks spring cleaning my makeup
what should i keep in my go-to arsenal
for makeup and how should i know to edit
oh we love a makeup edit right we love
it well the thing is you want something
minimal right you don't want loads and
loads of products so for that you want
to think about multitasking products
number one i would say for the spring is
coming you want something that is a
tinted moisturizer with an spf you want
your skin to look polished every day not
overdone you want people to basically
complement your skin not your makeup
the second thing i would say for spring
is a bright color eyeshadow right we're
seeing that all over is a big big trend
coming up blue coral green anything you
i mean it could be a liner it could be a
smudge on the eye something bright and
bold i love that right i think go to the
milk makeup uh website it's my favorite
company um rms makes a great little mini
palette that i'm obsessed with that has
a highlighter and a bronzer and a little
lip and cheek
um
and uh one thing i've realized is that i
have usually bought a lot of my products
in bulk
big mistake
don't do it i've had to throw out a few
things because they went past the
two-year mark and so i would also keep
it a minimalist
approach when you're buying your
products and cleansers skincare and
makeup you can always go out and buy
another but the fact that i have a few
that are expired breaks my heart and
makes me feel so wasteful you would
rather your product run out than it go
off yes exactly save the bulk buying for
the toilet roll agreed
um and for that i have a new bamboo
toilet paper that took me a minute to
get used to but i'm all for it now
saves trees and i paper towels and
toilet paper and they it's completely
sustainable
no trachealing
again it took me a second to get used to
i have this way too and and you know
she's a sturdy paper if you know what i
mean
she's not as she doesn't feel like
velvet
but she's not killing trees
[Applause]
thank you so much
[Music]
you